I had been familiar with the foreclosure
crisis through newspapers and whatnot
reading about what was happening in
articles and and while I had sympathy
for people that were going through that
experience the articles i don't think
painted a very vivid picture of what was
actually happening so they were very
technical and and laced with you know
funny names like Fannie Mac and Freddie
Mac or Fannie Mae or whatever I just
sounded all ridiculous and I i thought
well what's actually happening down
there and ramin went down there and and
did the research you know he spent time
with the people he spent time with
people on every aspect of the story
every side of the story and and got
everybody's point of view and
incorporated it into this amazing script
and yeah it's it's one of those scripts
you you can't put down I mean even the
the finance years you know people ask
where I mean a lot of times oh this must
have been very difficult to get this
movie financed and he gave it to five
finance ears and they all called him
back within 48 hours and said they
wanted to do it you know because the
script was that powerful you know and
what was it that really attracted you to
the role of Rick Carver he's a really
interesting guy well I don't I don't
know I kind of look at Rick is as like
an insect you know any people think of
him as you know obviously he is the
antagonist of the story in a classical
you know Greek sense but I I never
really looked at him as a villain I just
look at him it's somebody who deals with
the present circumstances and instead of
being victimized by them he figures out
a way to use them to his own advantage
you know you know when it went when I
was researching the role I spent a lot
of time with somebody who is in a very
similar situation to Rick
and he's not a bad guy like this guy I
was hanging out with he's a he's a
sweetheart really nice guy and you know
the thing that's important to remember
is that the the person I was studying
and Rick and the movie they didn't they
didn't get into the business to evict
people they got into the business to
sell real estate and then this happened
and somebody had to deal with it and it
got kind of foisted in their laps and
then they had to figure out how well
it's like you know like any business
persons like how do I make gold out of
this straw you know it's an opportunist
yeah yeah you know the other thing about
rick is that you know he's he's not
without remorse when Andrew Garfield's
character is getting evicted I mean he
felt bad and wasn't just like a typical
like villainous kind of role so what was
sort of a challenge to to not make him
not make Rick too sympathetic and also
not make him to villainous because you
really could have gone over and really
true the scenery by making him like a
dastardly villain my my system of
dealing with that conundrum was to not
give a [ __ ] I just didn't care like
because I don't think Rick cares I mean
I think Rick knows that lots of people
hate his guts and want to kill him but
he doesn't care it's not even
necessarily that he doesn't care but
it's not going to dissuade him from
doing what he's doing he doesn't have as
much as anybody in this story he doesn't
really have an option I mean what's he
going to do be a schoolteacher I mean
this is what he knows how to do it's
what he loves to do he loves what he's
doing it's what he's trained to do and
you know there are a lot of people in
the world I believe in this may sound a
little overly sentimental or whatever
but there are a lot of people in the
world that that I make a living off the
misfortune of other people I mean that's
just from my point of view the way it is
you know this is the same thing when I
was doing the Ice Man one
the reasons I wanted to do the Iceman
was like here's a guy who really wants
to have a family in a home and the way
he pays for that is he goes and you know
wax people you know so it was a similar
kind of thing I mean there are obviously
two very different characters but you
know i don't i don't really judge any of
the characters i play and I don't worry
about I don't necessarily worry about
how they're perceived or received by the
audience that's that's up to rom mean
because like Ricky's his his home has
there's nothing in it there's no
furniture there's no pictures on the
wall and you know this the way he he
smokes that cigarette me how much of
that was scripted about the character of
Rick and how much sort of evolved from
you like how much did you I mean I
followed the script very closely the
e-cigarette was remains idea you know
the all of the locations that was
remains vision every once in a while I
mean would literally asked me to help
him figure something out or you know
solicit and an improvisation from me and
I do have a bit of history and improv I
came up in Chicago doing Chicago theater
and I did improv there so I'm not I'm
not scared of improv but I really
respected the script and I wanted to do
it word for word and but every once in a
while he would ask me to think something
up you know famously I guess well not
famously it's not like it's gone with
the wind or something but I thought
we've talked about a great length the
ending of the film when Rick says thank
you that that's an improvisation because
rameen was he wasn't sure how to end
that relationship between Rick and
Dennis and he was very honest about it
he said I you know I've been working on
the script for months and I just I don't
know what the last moment between them
should be and in this
script it's just a look and he's like a
looks obviously not enough something's
got to happen but it's very complicated
because you're surrounded by the police
and you can't necessarily maybe say
exactly what's on your mind but you want
to tell him something because it's
probably the last time you're ever going
to talk to him and he would call me all
the time and say we need to have a
meeting about this go have a coffee talk
about I'm like no no we don't it's fine
we'll just figure he's like it's the end
of the movie i said i know i know but
does it just trust me something will
happen something will happen and and we
get there and we do the first take and
run means like um no no that's not gonna
work that's not right he's like I hope
you have another idea I was like I maybe
I don't know so we did another take and
and I said thank you and mommy was like
he said I'm gonna say two things a
that's that was right and and you know
is right because I could see you from
the monitor I looked over at you and you
were smiling like a Cheshire cat so I
know you knew that you got it right and
and be he's like I don't know what you
mean by thank you but I don't want you
to ever explain it to me or to anyone
else